avant de passer à bize aurait qu on va
faire un petit jeu inspiré de the voice
vous êtes prêts la table de sandwichs
non
on fait rentrer deux chanteurs est venu
dire celui qui chante le mieux et compte
y en a un qui chante bien vous retournez
d'accord d'accord
votre n'ont plus rien allez-y chanter
monsieur t
dos et la télé
à toi ça non
vers la voiture ça c'est déjà fait avec
l'interdît bancaire prenait ma femme le
canapé le micro le frigidaire et même
jusqu'à ma vie il est de toute façon on
a découvert ça convient dans mon âme au
diable
[Musique]
avec lui on peut s'arranger
puisque ici tout n'est conscient mais
vous n'aurez pas la liberté de pensée la
star joe est ce que vous pouvez
retourner ou pas
alors voit placé il chante juste un
petit peu vintage comme on dirait déjà
des petits tics et s'il est un peu âgées
c'est impossible à changer alors pour
faire le parcours bien faire la suite
alors monsieur
asseyez vous fait entrer le deuxième
chanteur s'il vous plaît
avant monsieur agents
[Musique]
ans
savoir sourire
à une inconnue qui passe
on gardait aucune trace
sinon ça fait plaisir
savoir aînés et
sans rien attendre en retour
higuain ni grand amour
même l'espoir d'être
et ça
dans les centres temps de ne cabon
et laissant à temps oui mais à tous
la souris
et
le geste de s'en vouloir de 20
apprendre
monsieur monter sur l'estrade tous les
deux clans attendu j'attends
votre avis alors j'ai une voix un peu
plus jeunes elles manquent de tissus il
a une bonne technique ça chante juste
aussi les deux chantent juste et sont
plutôt en place au départ tu sens que le
deuxième il est un peu plus stressé puis
après ça devient mieux mais il manque un
poil des tofs dans la voix et tu sais
que ben il faut plus de possibilités
pour la suite des événements est géré
est de performance et le gens que je
rencontre pensez vous alors je là j'ai
pas vu à mon avis allez-y je regarde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà c'est plus cool s'est dessaisi
mais vous avez tous les deux la
technique ça fonctionne et tout après
vous si on parlait moi j'étais en
référence de the voice en me disant le
voyage il est compliqué et l'eau surtout
que le premier il ya deux jours il
faisait zazie à la base
merci monsieur
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il mettait un peu
de bleu